[Music]
Ernest you're a good man aren't
you yes you're right I suppose
so you suppose so are you aren't
you personally speaking I became
painfully aware of the plate of the
Native Americans when I spent a period
of time in 1974 at Pim Ridge
reservation that experience was so
profound that it just stayed with me
through the last 50 years
so we Killers it was vitally important
to me to get every detail right so that
the audience feels the immensity of the
tragedy please send help there's murder
in O Sage the police do nothing there
was a need to tell this story from
Martin scorsi that's it there was
something intrinsic in him to do this
story
Justice that's how you are I don't know
what you said but it must have been
Indian for handsome devil
we worked closely with the oage
community to truly do right by making
this film we shot in the places that the
events actually occurred whose land is
this
Henry my
land my
land I knew I was going to be working on
a film that was very different from what
Marty had done before and I was so
thrilled to be editing it I've worked
with Marty for 50 odd years on 22
feature films this one is a challenge
because of its interesting structure
you're sometimes suddenly moved into a
different subject or a different
character who says are the finest and
most beautiful people on God's
[Music]
Earth I've fortunate to work with th
scoon maker more than 45 years she's a
wonderful artist and she edits with her
heart in this movie the actor's
performances are so wonderful I love the
great moment when Jesse says to Leo I
was sent down from Washington DC to see
about these murders see what about him
and Jesse says see who's doing it with a
little bit of humor Jesse has that quiet
confidence and a sense of rectitude is
perfect for the RO thank you sir in the
scenes that Marty wanted to leave
without subtitles I was a little
concerned about that but he was quite
right you hear the Osage and you do know
what what's going
on dairo has a way of pushing in the
knife and almost humanizing that and
it's interesting he's one of the few
people on this planet that can change
the temperature in a room by what
they're feeling so watching this master
create and form this character that was
incredibly inspiring well we mix these
families together and that estate money
flows the right direction it'll come to
us Molly this blanket is a Target on our
backs this scene is the core of the film
it shows the Journey of the relationship
of Molly and Earnest I need you here I
am right here as they start to kiss and
he moves with her he then improvised the
line oh you going try to wake the kids
up and he says I love you and he means
it that's the story of their love I am
to take care of
you when Marty shot the scene of Leo on
the stand we remark in the editing room
Leo is so brilliant and take one he was
so brilliant did your uncle present you
with a plan by which you would benefit
from the death of all these Indian
[Music]
women
yes it's staggering performance as the
editor you couldn't ask for anything
better we never use temp music in the
editing world room Marty begins to put
music into the film right away the only
person who should do the music for the
film was Robbie Robertson it's
remarkable watching Marty compose a film
Marty obsessed with telling the story
with the most honesty that he possibly
could Martin scorsi and his team are so
respectful he talked to several Elders
to get the correct version of our
traditions and history and culture
expressed in this movie we're so honored
to have been entrusted to be part of
such an historic moment of
representation we all made it together
there was not a moment where I didn't
have the oage with us like a family with
the cast and a crew that was deeply
committed to telling this powerful
historical story in the proper and most
authentic
way I'm sorry for all
troubles